[Musique]
allez on termine avec les résultats
sportifs du week-end de michael et demi
d'euros bonsoir calgary journalistes aux
sports de la rédaction tv 78 du football
pour commencer michael le championnat de
2e division de district deux équipes et
un seul et même objectif survivre dans
ce championnat de d2 de district villes
pro recevait la réserve de versailles ce
dimanche 9 février après une première
période équilibrée ce sont finalement
les versaillais qui arrivent à faire la
différence
1 à 0 ce sera le score à la pause au
retour des vestiaires sous une pluie
battante et le vent les deux équipes ont
du mal à produire leurs meilleures
partitions versailles réalisera tout de
même le break score final 2 à 0 au
classement l'équipe 3 de versailles est
toujours 11e et revient à hauteur des
premiers à non-relégable de son côté
gilles proulx est toujours bon dernier
avec une seule victoire depuis le début
de la saison on écoute l'entraîneur des
villes prochain ils ont pris un petit
coup quand le faux pas relâché il ya
encore des matches à jouer
la saison est encore longue on n'est
jamais n'est jamais à l'abri d'un d'un
miracle pour continuer à croire au
miracle villes pro se déplacera sur le
terrain de montesson le dimanche 1er
mars également dû is portes ce week end
et place prisée ya un public qui répond
présent la troisième édition du touriste
porte a de nouveau fait le plein ce
week-end à versailles plus de 200
joueurs se sont affrontés durant tout un
après-midi amateurs comme professionnels
après deux saisons tourner autour de eur
stone le tournoi est ouvert à de
nouveaux jeux du football avec fifa 20
et league of legends le numéro un du
monde de lys porte qui vient de fêter à
ses 10 ans l'idée c'était que les jeux
c'est un peu comme des disciplines
sportives
on a beau être sportif si on joue pas au
rugby on m'a pas forcément sur le rugby
donc là l'idée c'était d'avoir plus de
diversité plus de personnes qui étaient
intéressés mais pas forcément sur un
seul jeu
donc là ça a permis d'avoir des
communautés trois joueurs on peut
imaginer qu'un art entre les deux caps
les vainqueurs se sont partagé près de
4000 euros de dotation les équipes
pensent déjà à une quatrième édition
merci michael le reste de l'actualité
sportive notamment un résultat des
templiers d'elancourt en foot us à
retrouver dans un instant votre émission
le 7-8 sport sur tv 78